( ´ー｀)ﾌｩｰ．．．
ディズニーランド行きたい！ディズニーランドに行きたい！
僕ディズニーランドに行きたい！えーもうなんかいつ行ったんだろう？
ディズニーシーは多分3，4年前ぐらいに行ったんですよ
3，4年前かそれでも！！3，4年前に行ったのはたしか
覚えてて…
でもそれ以降はもう全然行ってないです(´・ω・`)
行ってないなぁ…行ってない！行ってない！！ディズニーランドに
行ってないよ!!(;´Д｀)
ディズニーランドに関しては…多分…
もう10年ぐらい行ってないんじゃないかな？！
大学1,2年…え？3年で行ったかな
それぐらいでシー行って以来…多分
ディズニーフレンズには全く行ってないです
はじめしゃちょーです(自己紹介長いな…)
悲しいよ…僕悲しい僕悲しいよ
ディズニー行きたいよ！（泣）
ディズニー行きてぇ久しぶりに！
そんで今東京に住んでるからもうディズニー行くなら
今しかない！と思ってるんですよ僕は！
やっぱりこうあの〜アレなんですよね
人多い場所に行くと
声掛けてくださったり、写真撮ったりすると
他の周りの人がバーッと気づいちゃって、こうバーッとなっちゃって
もうすぐ多分2ちゃんとかNAVERまとめとかで
『≪悲報≫はじめしゃちょーディズニーで迷惑行為』
って出るのはもう目に見えてると思うので
僕はもう、ディズニーに行くことを許されない、そう言いたいんだろ？
だが逆に考えてみるんだ、逆の発想を持つと…！
バレなきゃいいんや
要するにはじめしゃちょーってバレなきゃ
僕は多分ディズニーランドで遊んでも良いと思うんですよ！
なので今回は
今からちょっとディズニーランド1人で行ってくるんですけども
ディズニーランドでバレたらすぐ帰ってきます
逆に！もうバレるまでなら僕はずっと今日ディズニーランドで遊んでます
閉園までな( ≖ิ‿≖ิ )
イヤ、ヤバイ
え〜1人でしょ
いや1人はしくったなちょっと…凄い…嫌になってきました
え〜ちょっとこの服装はちょっとトミックさんに借りたんですけど
もうちょっとディズニーぽい服を買いたいと思うんで
ディズニーランドの近くにある、なんかそういうショップがあるらしいんですよ、色々買える
とりあえずそのなんかディズニーランドに入る用のオシャレな被り物とか
そういうアレを買って、装備してからディズニーランドに潜入しようと思います
僕変装したくないんですよね…
何故かと言いますと…
暑いんすよね…なんかマスクとか、本当はマスクもしたくない…
あっバレッ…あっギリセーフだな
あとなんか僕、帽子とかもそんなに好きな方じゃないんで
なんかこう変装して行くのはちょっと違うかなという
僕としてディズニーランドに行きたいので
ちょっと今回の企画もね、変装は逃げだと思ってるんで
変装はせずに行きます
俺だけ早アri…俺だけはやruあru…あの…俺だけ早
バレてない…
イケる！！！！
もうどこが入り口かもよく分かんないんですよね
あ絶対ココだ
バレるバレる
久しぶりですね〜
やべ普通に行きてえわ
変装グッズが買えるショップまではこのままマスクして行きます
ただもうランド入る直前はマスクつけませんから
はいというわけで、今のうちにもう変装しちゃいましょう
もうとりあえずもう正直マスクさえつけずにバレなきゃもう大丈夫だと思ってるんで
後はなるべくこのグッズをつけて僕っていうことがバレなければもうオッケーだと思います
いやなかなか分かんないっしょ
いやこれではじめしゃちょーって分かる人はそういないと思うんですよね
いやサングラスはデカいな。
多分サングラスをつけることによって全然はじめしゃちょー感は無くなると思うので
ディズニーランド、満喫してこようと思います
いやぁイケる！俺これはイケるぞ！ちょっと行ってくるわもう
では、行ってきます！
逆に怪しまれてんな
これ可笑しいのかな…すごい怪しまれてる気がする
シシ、シャーー
じゃあ並びます！
荷物チェックか…
いやぁ〜最初の門がキツいなぁ
荷物チェックはクリアしました
後はこのままチケットを買って
中に入って遊ぶだけです
人目は気になるんですけど
こうやっぱ…そんな…
いやバレてんのかな
ちょっと人目は気になるものの、多分バレてはいないです
イケるぞ…！もう目の前だ…！
よし行くぞ
あっ！( ﾟДﾟ)
♪無限大な夢のあとの
♪何もない世の中じゃ
♪そうさ愛しい
♪想いも負けそうになるけど
♪Stayしがちなイメージだらけの
♪頼りない翼でも
♪きっと飛べるさ
♪On My Love